[music]
ran
This is it
[music]
What kind
of dinner did you
have
here?
However, while the other models are fighting with their swords drawn, Yusaku
why don't you do that?
First and foremost is the military standard librarian, who was momentarily given to him by His Majesty the Emperor
.  It
's not like that.
Please kill this man. God,
this is it.
]
For the soldiers around Puncha, it's raw, so the
base is a virgin in order to inherit the key.
If you're going to give courage to someone next to you, then if everyone doesn't take people
Brenda Because yakuza will happen,
guilt
[music]
Is it guilt for wanting to kill?
Anita Marquis isn't that kind of person, I'm sure you know
.